everybody welcome to the show hope we
had a great weekend as you can see I am
dressed in my all-black outfit again
just in case you know I happen to run
into a funeral today or a bank I want to
rob or I want to enter the matrix or
anything like that then I've you know
I'm ready to go I've got the I've got
the costume on now I want to talk about
this Kevin Williamson situation maybe if
you if you're not on Twitter you maybe
haven't even heard about it Kevin
Williamson was hired by his a
conservative writer right-wing writer at
least and he was hired by the Atlantic
which as you probably know was
traditionally a leftist publication
hired by them few weeks ago has now been
fired before I believe he even wrote
anything for the Atlantic he's already
been fired because of a coordinated and
relentless smear campaign against him by
the left and the Atlantic caved to that
pressure after only a couple of weeks
this in spite of the fact that Kevin
Williamson is one of the most talented
writers in America and he really is one
of the most out that I'm not just saying
that he's one of the most talented
writers in America and one of the most
interesting writers because he doesn't
he doesn't pander and that's a very rare
quality among commentators and pundits
and columnist and writers on both sides
of the spectrum most of what you get on
both sides of the spectrum with these
peas these paid opinion givers most of
them all they do is just pander they
have their audience and they've got
their base of support and they just tell
those people ages echo they they figure
out whatever those people are already
thinking and they's echo those thoughts
back to them and even simpler in less
nuanced terms than they're already
thinking it so they're just kind of
they're just a wall to bounce your own
opinions off of and that makes them
bland and boring and just painfully
painfully dull Williamson doesn't do
that that's what makes him interesting
but he's been he's been fired the thing
that got Williamson into trouble well
really the thing that got him into
trouble is just that he's
not on the left that he's considered
part of the right-wing and so that's why
they hate him but and they would have
wanted to destroy him and get him kicked
out of the mainstream anyway he was a
part of the National he was writing for
the National Review before then if if
you're a conservative person and you try
to leave the conservative spear and go
to something considered more mainstream
then the left is going to react against
that and try to and try to get they're
gonna find a reason to kick you back to
the conservative camp the reason that
they found for Kevin Williamson is that
he has stated on a few occasions that he
believes that women who have had
abortions should be hanged now I don't
think he meant this literally okay it's
it's kind of clear to me that he's not
actually stating his his a plan or
something he's and he's not saying that
women right now today who have had
abortions should be hanged what he's
talking about is well if abortion is
illegal and it's legally murder
well that means what it means that's
what he actually said
now most pro-lifers myself included
would oppose the idea of executing women
who get abortions
however it's not in a rational or
delusional point of view because in a
world where abortion is illegal it would
and should be treated as murder which is
the point he's trying to make so if you
are someone who supports capital
punishment and a lot of pro lifers don't
which is the first reason why they
wouldn't execute anybody involved with
abortions is because they don't they
don't believe in executing anyone at all
but if you believe in capital punishment
and you believe in capital punishment
for people who commit murder
particularly murder of children well
then there's an there's kind of an
obvious connection here personally I
wouldn't support that because I believe
you know capital murder charges should
be reserved for the abortionists who not
only carry out these these these
killings but also take advantage of and
exploit women and young girls who are
often often ignorant
they're scared and the abortion industry
takes advantage of them that doesn't
alleviate their moral guilt entirely and
there's no doubt that many of them go
into the procedure with very clear eyes
they know what they're doing and
calloused hearts and there are women who
get multiple abortions and they just
don't care at all about the lives of
these children and so there's just that
callousness there but I also think that
a lot of people don't understand the the
level of exploitation that goes on and
this is a really important part of the
pro-life message this is something we
need to communicate people don't
understand the level of exploitation and
just the the the scare tactics that
these abortion clinics use and the ways
in which they they ensure that these
women remain in the dark and remain
ignorant they don't want them to have
any information that's why they're
always opposed to oh no we can't we
can't let them see a sonogram we can't
give them any information if you try to
pass any law at all imposing any
standards on these clinics or saying
look you need to equip these women with
at least some information about what
you're doing to them any amount of that
whatsoever the the clinics react against
even though everything they consider
themselves a medical right there they're
a medical clinic well any other medical
clinic you go to there are all kinds of
laws and regulations and if they're
going to perform any procedure on you
whatsoever they have to they have to
give you there are all kinds of laws
requiring the clinic or the medical
establishment to provide information
there are not nearly as many such laws
for abortion clinics why is that because
the abortion clinics want these women to
be ignorant they want them in the dark
because if you're if you're in the dark
and you're ignorant and you're already
in the situation where you're pregnant
and you don't what to do then that's
gonna breed fear and then the abortion
clinic they take that fear and they use
it and they profit off of it and they
turn it into death and that's how they
convince these women's these women
often times to kill their babies and to
give up this precious gift this this
gift of motherhood and to give it up
without fully realizing what they're
doing and that's why if we're gonna you
know give first degree capital murder
charges to anybody it should be the
abortion the abortionists and the
officials in these abortion clinics but
however you feel on that subject and
whether you think that Williamson's
position is correct or horrifying or
somewhere in between I think there two
things are immediately clear here that I
want to cover first of all it's very
chilling and this is the thing that most
people are focusing on it's very
chilling that a writer can be fired for
his political beliefs especially when he
was hired to communicate those beliefs
after a coordinated assault on his
character and especially when by the way
it's not like he was hired for the
Atlantic and then he the first thing he
did was write an article about executing
women this is something that he
mentioned in a tweet and in a podcast
well before he was ever hired by the
Atlantic and as far as I know he's never
he's never proposed it in any kind of
writing that anyone has paid him to
write so really he's getting fired for
his opinions and his personal beliefs
after this assault that was waged
against him which was completely
politically motivated and that's a
pretty chilling thing but here's here's
the bigger point every pro-abortion
columnist and pundit in the country
harbors views that are infinitely more
offensive and disgusting and outrageous
and shocking than Williamson's now he
may hypothetically be suggesting capital
punishment for people who kill their
babies but pro-abortion people
pro-abortion people and there are
obviously millions of them out there and
there are hundreds of them in the media
pro-abortion people support the actual
real-life execution of human children
let me ask you which position is more
shocking the supporting the hypothetical
execution of people who kill their kids
or supporting the real life actually
happening now mass execution of 60
million human babies because that's the
position that every pro-abortion person
in the country holds 60 million babies
have been executed and executed in ways
that are far more gruesome than hanging
by the way if you look into how these
abortion procedures are carried out it's
not a you know when we say that these
that these babies are slaughtered and
butchered and ripped apart that's
actually what happens that's how these
procedures are carried out but the
pro-abortion crowd they not only support
this wholesale slaughter of babies but
they applaud it they applaud it they
applaud it as as as this victory for
womanhood this victory for you know
self-actualization autonomy so that's
what's so ironic here
that's what's ironic that only pro
lifers only pro lifers have any ground
to stand on when it comes to criticizing
Williamson now we can we can criticize
each other within our own movement we
have them we have the moral leg to stand
on because we're the ones opposed to
killing babies but guess what if you
support killing babies you don't get to
act shocked or outraged at anyone's
opinion on any subject because you have
the most disgusting awful
indefensible position of
available in the world so you don't you
don't get to do that you don't get to
turn to anyone else and say how could
you possibly believe that you don't get
to do that while you stand on the graves
of 60 million dead babies sorry but
pro-lifers while they will and many of
them have criticized kevin Williamson's
position argued against that they would
never call for his firing yeah it's only
the probe baby killing Hippocrates who
would join that course and that's why
they should be completely ignored but
you see here okay you see the let the
strategy that the left employees and it
is a devastatingly effective strategy so
we should we should look at this and
learn something from it what the left
does especially when it comes to
abortion but really when it comes to any
position at all that they don't like
you'll notice they they want when you
articulate a point of view that they
don't like they're not just going to say
oh I disagree with that I understand
where you're coming from but I disagree
with it
let's engage in a discussion they're not
going to say that they're going to
recoil in in horror okay they're going
to act like what you just said is the
most disgusting insane idiotic thing
that anyone has ever uttered there
they're going to say that not only is
this position wrong but it is not fit
for human civilization it is not a
position that anyone should hold in a
human society in a civilized society
they're going to shriek they're gonna
snarl and they will generally give off
the impression that the person who said
whatever this thing is is just
completely delusional and horrific and
evil that's how they act and it's a
smart strategy
okay it works it obviously works
the only problem is that it's dishonest
but there's not necessarily any problem
with reacting to somebody's opinion that
way because if they really do have a
horrific ly stupid and awful opinion
well then it should be treated that way
so the problem is not quite it's not
really their reaction it's what they're
reacting to it's that they react to the
truth that way and the truth does not
deserve to be treated that way Kevin
Williamson even if you disagree with
this position on executing people get
abortions it's grounded in the truth in
that it's grounded in in the belief that
it's completely wrong and awful to kill
babies and that's what the left is
really reacting against that's what they
don't it's it's that that they want to
it's that's what they're punishing I
think the pro-lifers would do well to
adopt a little bit of this approach and
in their case it would be okay in our
case it would be okay because it would
be honest the pro-abortion position is
actually and really horrific disgusting
crazy irredeemable and it should be
treated that way that's how we should
treat it one of the problems among pro
lifers especially the kind of nominal
Pro lifers but even many sincere and
active pro lifers is that we listen to
the pro-abortion side and we like take
it seriously and we treat that we treat
the opinion with respect we've got
someone up there saying yes 60 million
dead babies let's kill more and we sit
there and we listen and we say oh yeah
okay well let's you know let's engage in
a dialogue about that we should be the
ones recoiling in discussed what we
should be the ones saying I'm not even
going to entertain that view if you have
that
you then then I can't take anything you
say seriously the problem is that there
are many conservatives pro-lifers who
who say that for instance they'll say
that well we shouldn't call abortion
baby murder and so forth we shouldn't
call pro-abortion people pro-abortion we
shouldn't use words like slaughter and
butcher we shouldn't do that we should
adopt the language that the left has
assigned to us we should play the game
on their terms we should adopt all the
same code words that they use we should
help them cover up their evil deeds in
all these nice little sanitary
euphemisms we should be polite we should
be reasonable we should afford their
position respect you know we should lead
by example and be the mature and
respectable ones know our position okay
I have no problem saying this call me a
hypocrite on abortion my position is due
respect I am due respect as a pro-life
person my position is respectable and
you should respect it if you're Pro
pro-abortion your position is not
respectable and it is not due respect
and I do not respect it I'm going that's
what I guess what I'm gonna demand that
you respect my position even why I don't
even while I don't respect yours because
your position is not respectable you are
arguing for murdering babies
I'm not going to respect that I'm saying
we shouldn't you should respect that if
you're a decent and civilized human
being your position in that case is
murderous and wicked and ridiculous and
anti science and not grounded in any
kind of reality or logic at all now
I know that obviously different
occasions call for different approaches
and there are plenty of situations when
you're pro-life or when you've got to be
more gentle and maybe you don't go
throwing around words like slaughter and
butcher and baby killing for instance
sidewalk counselors who are who just
have a wonderful and godly ministry
where they're the ones who go to the
clinics and they're trying to approach
these women as they're walking into the
clinics and minister to them and provide
them with information and show them love
and show them support so a sidewalk
counselor is not going to run up no
matter how no matter the caricature of
pro-lifers that pro-bush people use that
the reality is that sidewalk counselors
they're not going to run to a woman and
say oh you're killing a baby and so
forth they're gonna go up and show
support and show love and that's very
very effective in that situation because
again these women walking into the
clinic they're there they are they have
been made to be afraid what while the
the message on the pro-life side is
don't be afraid you know don't be afraid
of motherhood don't be afraid of this
situation that you're in
it's a blessing embrace it the the
message on the on the for the for the
abortion clinic their message is be
afraid be very very afraid your life is
over all you can do is kill your baby
it's the only thing you could do no
other no other solution is going to work
for you so that's why the sidewalk
counselors have to go up with a message
of with a gentle loving message but the
national conversation about abortion
okay when we are generally talking about
abortion or when we as pro-lifers are
you know generally communicating our
position to a to it to a large audience
like I'm doing now that conversation
cannot be had in the tone and using the
language of a sidewalk counselor because
the vast vast majority of people in our
culture who are engaging in this
conversation
they're it's they're not just about to
have abortions most of them have never
had abortions what it is for most people
when it comes to abortion the position
that most people have is
they just want to live in peace and not
be forced to confront the horror of this
Holocaust and most pro-abortion people
that's all they want they just they want
to say okay yeah go ahead and kill the
babies I don't care let me just sit here
and watch TV don't bother me about it
and so that's why we as Pro lifers we
have to come in okay they want that
peace and that tranquility and they want
to ignore what's going on we have to
take that peace from them and take that
tranquility from them and force them to
confront the horror that they support we
have to fort they have no right you live
in a country where 60 million babies
have been killed you have no right to
look away from it you have no right to
ignore it you don't
and so as pro lifers we have to force
you we have to take this bored apathetic
lazy cowardly effeminate ridiculous
culture and slap some sense into it and
force them to confront the reality of
this Holocaust that is happening right
now all around us that's the strategy
and the tactic that we should use okay
we have to stop we have essentially when
it comes in the abortion conversation
it's the pro-abortion people who have
cornered the market on this kind of
moral righteous indignation
they're the ones who react like how dare
you I can't believe that you would ever
say something like that and we let them
do it we let them act like they're the
ones who not only have the moral
position but their position but but that
but have the position that is self
evidently obviously the most moral and
the most correct and they're the ones
who support killing sixty million human
babies we need to take that ground from
them and every single person who
supports executing babies we should
treat them we should treat their
position the way that the left has
treated Kevin Williamson I'm not saying
we try to get them fired from their jobs
but we treat that position as just
horrific and wrong and not even worth
this you know it's like we can't even
listen to that side of the discussion
because it is so completely insane we
have a right to react that way because
we're the ones who are trying to protect
babies or being killed alright thanks
for watching everybody and I'll talk to
you tomorrow